[Music]
so the Black Panther trailer dropped
today unless you've been living under a
particularly heavy nerd rock it's a
thing that you were captivated by this
morning the way the rest of us were
before we talked about it
it's worth talking a little bit about
what a trailer supposed to do the
purpose of a trellis is just to make you
excited to Bob and the way it sells that
product is and you can't sell any
product unless you know exactly what it
is you're selling and the best trailers
have an absolute manner of steel which
which I love it's selling you on
iconography it's selling you on on the
dream of Superman you look at Wonder
Woman it is selling you on on grace
under fire it's selling you on
reclaiming the space if you look at the
Avengers it is selling you on
culmination it is selling you on holy
[ __ ]
all of these heroes we've been watching
or now on screen together and oh my god
this is amazing you look at Gardens the
galaxies it's selling you on space rock
you look at Justice League and part of
the problem with that trailer is that we
don't know what it is they're selling I
don't think they know where it is there
someone it seems to be red skies and and
bad jokes but I'm sure there's more than
movie than that that has to be otherwise
why do you spend 300 million dollars on
something and you look at the black
panther trailer and it is selling you on
pride either selling you on unequivocal
unapologetic pride on who black panther
is on hooter chala is on what Wakanda is
on what it means to be from that place
in this time and given given the world
we live in it is selling prized selling
black pride in a very real way is is
almost a transgressive act and that's
part of the reason why at least for me
it seems at this these trailers both the
first one in this one carries such a
charge to them it's it is it is almost
revolution
for a movie like this to exist at a time
like now and that part of that is
because of Ryan Coogler you know Kevin
I've talked about our undying unyielding
love for Creed and and parentheses I am
kind of sad that he's not returning for
Creed to solicit Alana's gonna write and
direct the sequel to that it'll still
have Michael B Jordan because you can't
have create two without Creed but Ryan
Coogler is bringing two Black Panther
this this very real sense of texture and
I've lived in quality and what Conda
does not feel like it's you know a a
kingdom of [ __ ] which which all too
often kind of alternate realities hidden
cities can feel like they feel like
sketches they feel like on the periphery
there's some cool stuff but in the
center there's not much holding on we
see even in these two minutes you just
get this sense that Wakanda is a real
place you get the sense that it's a city
that functions you get a sense that it
has history real history and that
history will be part of what causes the
issues that the child will face I mean
in right from the beginning right from
the music right from everything right
from from dennah grammar saying we are
home and all of all of these amazing
actors doing their best sort of mid
continental African accents it it feels
like a tapestry that we just haven't
gotten a chance to see before you know
Michael B Jordan looks fantastic as kill
monger you know and it seems as if his
story I mean we're we're absolutely just
embroidering and and trying to connect
dots that we don't have all the context
for but he seems to be you know sir the
excommunicated son if not the actual
brother of T'Challa at least a spiritual
brother to Charlie who went down the
wrong path
and it's not returning to claim what he
believes is his through violence in
through fire we get to see the the
relationships that T'Challa has with the
women in his life
you know between angela bassett as his
mom and den i Guerrera as his chief
bodyguard and an Lupita Nyong'o as from
what I understand something of a spy
slash information gatherer / ex paramour
of T'Challa all of these people who are
functioning as both support and as you
know the the rails on the side of that
the bumper cars to make sure you don't
go off the rail and his conscience in a
way in in in pushing the child to the
place where he can choose the kind of
king that he wants to be you know and
just there's so much texture and there's
so much [ __ ] badassery in this trailer
I mean the same when when when when Andy
Serkis is Ulysses Clos I guess that's
how we're gonna pronounce it some things
about like KL aue
or whatever it'll leans out of a car and
shoots its awesome weapon and blows up
the car and T'Challa like flips off of
the car and up against the building and
lands back on it and then carves the
front tire off of the [ __ ] I mean
it's it's almost exhausting to keep up
with the amount of innovation and
invention that's going on on the screen
and that's being wielded with such a
sure hand you know you can see movies
like this you can even see trailers for
movies like this that feel as if they
were created before the actual movie was
that they had the three or four shots
that they knew they wanted for the
trailer they had there two or three
sequences they know they wanted to
highlight and those might have even been
in place before an actual director was
brought on board I mean you know Joss
Whedon had gone on record saying that
when he took the Avengers job there were
there were three or four sequences that
he knew they wanted that they told him
they wanted and so part of his job was
to stitch the connective tissue between
those big giant sequences this feels
like it is from whole cloth out of ryan
quarles breath and for sure I'm there
there were I'm going to assume that
there were mandates from Marvel because
again you don't spend you know twenty
million dollars our movie and not how
mandator - but you know it was made more
as the producer who works at Marvel who
was shepherding this project and Brian
came in to write and direct it and it
feels like it's bespoke to that guy and
his vision and everything about this
trailer feels like it's part of that
vision and it's just it's it's totally
enthralling and and intensely satisfying
to see even in there's these little bits
they're not giving us very much of the
plot
we don't where we're we're just
insinuating what might happen or what
might not happen but they're giving us
the mood they're selling us on that
pride they're selling us on that this is
a place for you in the same way that
Wonder Woman sold you the battlefield is
the place for Diana what Conda is the
place for T'Challa and you know and the
movies absolutely seems to be with this
apparent civil war will have vast
ramifications on both from all the
universe I'm assuming and the world
outside of them all the universe within
the Marvel Universe movies I know that
was a little bit tortured but whatever
gives [ __ ] I mean I can't I February
cannot come fast enough you know it
seems to be the kind of movie that
people like me fans like me longtime
fans of Marvel Comics who've watched
this character since its generation
since its inception in the early 70s and
watch them blossom and watch them
blossom under the the priest run watch
them blossom under the townhouse ecoach
run to see this executed at such a level
with such craft of care and sensitivity
and and just understanding that whatever
else this movie is going to be in
whatever else it needs to be it must
also be a pulp adventure I mean it's
it's a jungle King it is this is the
kind of thing that pubs were built on
even back when they were mostly racist
traps written by guys who did not and
had no interest in exploring the world
around
but you know guys like you know Robert E
Howard who created Conan
guys like Arthur Conan Doyle guys like
you know whoever that dude invented
Tarzan was whose name escapes me but all
of those things like King Solomon's
Mines they were all you know the noble
why the hero plunges into the deepest
darkest Africa to ultimately rape it of
whatever made it special be it gold or
diamonds or oil or ancient artifacts or
you name it they took it this is this is
the closing of that loop this is taking
some of those jungle tropes and and
recasting them redefining them we
reforging them into something better
something smarter something way more
contemporary and something that deserves
to sit alongside the other kinds of
movies that we love that that treat
their characters with the same amount of
respect so yeah I mean I I'm running out
of things to say about these two minutes
but I cannot imagine running out of ways
to feel about black panther between now
and February and Jesus when if February
comes I mean weird I we're all gonna
take the month off right like that's
just what we're doing we're all just
gonna celebrate it back Panther for a
month and if not you should just talk to
your people and and and we'll all fun
what there's a home for everybody in
Wakanda so yeah for this this baby
episode of famine on Batman I've been
mark barnard and yeah let us know what
you think on the Internet's where you
can find either of us or at the comments
below which we do actually kind of read
even though I know you're not supposed
to read the comments I still read the
comments so yeah [ __ ] Black Panther
bro Hawaii yeah peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you